[Music]
we begin with breaking news
pharmaceuticals giant
pfizer has announced that its
anti-coronavirus vaccine
developed in partnership with german
company beyond tech is 90 percent
effective two companies are the first to
show successful data from a large-scale
trial of such a vaccine pfizer and
beyond tech say they've found no serious
safety concerns
and expect to seek authorization for
emergency use in the united states of
this
this month
so let's explore this with tobias court
who's an epidemiologist at berlin
charity hospital
welcome to dw how significant do you
feel this news is
well i think this is a significant step
and we know that
several companies are working on
vaccines and we were
hoping to hear this news uh soon and so
today we heard the news however we have
to understand this is an interim
analysis so this is not the end of the
trial that is currently still ongoing
and it's a press release so we have not
seen the data in detail but we are very
positive that this data holds true and
that a lot of people who are
vaccinated are protected from getting
corona
so are you able to to see from the the
details that have been released so
far have you been able to see um what it
is 90
effective at doing and for how long
as far as i understand there were two
vaccinations and necessary
and after these two vaccinations a
certain number of people still get six
and ninety percent doesn't mean that
everyone is protected but from the
people who are participating in the
trial
90 did not get uh kovitz
after two vaccinations but again this is
an interim analysis
and more data are coming in right these
results as you say
are these are results from trials so
what now has to happen successfully
before
any vaccine can be rolled out
well we need to wait until the closure
of the trial we also need to follow very
say
very carefully the safety information
which you already mentioned
so far there do not seem to be concerns
about a safety
and then we have to see when the vaccine
is rolled out
that we follow people who have been
vaccinated to really
see whether any issues occur and we also
have to understand that when the drug is
released to the market that not suddenly
the problem is solved because people
need to get vaccinated and not everyone
will have the vaccination
in the first days or weeks or
potentially even months
now this vaccine uses a new technology
called
messenger rna technology i wonder if you
could explain that to us in
simple terms yes so what you take you
you do not take the virus on anti-change
you take a
messenger rna from the antigen of the
virus and inject that
to the body and the immune system cells
are taking this messenger rna
inside of the cell and then producing
the antigen on the surface of the cell
and by that attacking the virus so this
is a very
neat way of of a vaccine important also
is that a very different ways of
vaccines currently produced
so if if this is not working for
everyone then maybe the other ones are
working for those
in which this vaccine is not working
vaccines often take upwards of 10 years
to be
developed yet here we are not even a
year into this pandemic
what will have what corners will have
been cut what will not have been done
that usually gets done to get a vaccine
this far this fast
yes covet 19 is new but the coronavirus
isn't so this is not like we're
developing a drug
with absolutely no information before so
there have been some work before and
that was
the reason why the companies are able
now so fast
to actually find a potential solution to
produce a vaccine
so what we have to follow is really to
see what's happening on the population
level
is it really as effective as in the
trials and are the side effects or not
so the are there concerns about
potential
adverse long-term reactions to the the
uh anti-covid drugs are
being developed just because
this this development process has been
so contracted
i think that everyone's working very
carefully and specifically we are
concerned about safety and so
this is really this information is
really collected very carefully
we also know from other vaccines that
there are no major
side effects and the long-term
consequences obviously
we know in in a couple of years but
taking together all the information from
other vaccines i did not expect any
major consequences
in particular now what we know from the
from the trial short-term side effects
are not expected
so given what we've heard and i
appreciate you saying it was a press
release
is this a vaccine you would take
i would take this vaccine if offered to
me
again i would like to see the data
before but this data will be released
i'm sure
and the officials in the united states
as well as in europe are very carefully
looking at this data before it's
actually
released to the public so many many
people are looking
at this very carefully and no one has an
interest that
something is released which will cause
side effects or any issues we hope to
solve the issue of kovit to solve the
issue of the pandemic and hopefully that
we
are slowly getting back to to a life
that
maybe not what we used to live but but
certainly without a fear
of a massive pandemic wave good talking
to you thank you for joining us dr
tobias kurt from berlin's charity
hospital
thank you for having me millions of
doses could be ready by the end of the
year
still the experimental vaccine is not
the only one being developed
there are about 200 of them around 40
are in clinical trials
and there are different methods being
used to make them
various kinds of vaccine for coronavirus
are in development one kind is an
inactivated virus vaccine that uses
proteins from the virus
to create the vaccine viruses first have
to be broken down into parts
and their infectivity has to be
destroyed so it's no longer dangerous
but it still has to provoke an immune
response in the recipient so that the
immune system develops antibodies to it
so what are the advantages and
disadvantages
this approach is well established
companies that develop and manufacture
vaccines are familiar with it
and the production processes have been
perfected
but certainly an advantage
the disadvantage is that it takes time
to grow
the underlying virus in large amounts if
more
is needed
a viral vector vaccine uses a harmless
live virus of a different kind
as a carrier to transport genes from the
dangerous virus
into cells in the recipient's body
a protein gene from the bad virus is
first added to the benign one
in the case of the novel coronavirus
it's a spike protein gene
the modified virus then resembles sars
cov2 in one
key respect the immune system detects
the offending protein
and creates antibodies in response
the safety requirements for growing the
virus are not as strict as with
inactivated whole virus vaccines
disadvantages are that it takes a lot of
time and you have to choose vectors that
are not affected by any pre-existing
immune response capability
then there are vaccines that use
messenger rna
for the novel coronavirus it is mrna
with instructions for making its spike
proteins
such vaccines prompt cells in the
recipient to make such proteins
themselves
which in turn provoke an immune response
although these proteins are not
dangerous
they are still identified as enemies by
the immune system
which then creates antibodies and thus
[Music]
immunity
one advantage is that the safety
requirements are much less stringent
another is that you can modify the rna
quite quickly
manufacturers say that within a short
period of time
perhaps six weeks rna vaccines can be
produced in very large volumes
millions of units you can't match that
with vector
whole virus or other kinds of vaccine
so each of these approaches has upsides
and downsides
nonetheless they're all considered worth
pursuing it is likely that we need more
than one vaccine
anna blakeney is a bioengineer and joins
us from london
what's the problem here anna if if we
totally rely on one or more vaccines
coming along to solve
this crisis yeah so
uh really you know we have a lot of
different tools that we can use
to fight this pandemic so you know if
you were being approached by a swarm of
mosquitoes
and you had the choice to use a net a
flyswatter and
bug spray or something you wouldn't
choose to use just one of them
so in addition to vaccines and the many
different vaccines that we might have
available
you want to also be using masks and
public health measures like social
distancing as well
even if we do get a vaccine or more
vaccines at some
stage soon i hope it's not going to be
an immediate fix is it no
no definitely not so it will take some
time to roll it out to the population
but even when you receive a vaccine
depending on the type of vaccine it can
take anywhere from two to six weeks
to induce immunity so there's still a
little bit of a lag time
i know there are a lot of people out
there who aren't going to want to take
that vaccine or those vaccines how
has misinformation on vaccines made your
job difficult
yeah so we often view it as people that
are pro-vaccine or anti-vaccine
and i really think it's kind of a gray
area in between so i'm part of a new
team called team halo which is an
initiative to connect
scientists working on coven 19 vaccines
directly to
the public and we do this through tick
tock so we're able to make videos about
how we make vaccines how we test them
and then be there to answer any
questions that people have
so it's a really great way to connect
with people who are skeptical or
critical
and you know i don't really think that's
a bad thing as scientists we're
taught to be critical until we see the
data and often the public isn't um you
know
proxy to that data data or doesn't know
how to interpret it and so
it's great to be able to connect and
have um actual conversations with people
and you're making all of this process
transparent which is important
i'd like to know where all the
misinformation on vaccines actually
comes from
um i think it's just in general you know
there might not be a lot of people that
are educated on
vaccines or how they work and so when
stuff starts to kind of just stew
um in the internet there a lot of rumors
fly around and
you know sometimes people just don't
know what to trust anymore so
we're there to kind of improve that
trust and just be a direct
source where you can ask questions and
get an honest answer from a scientist
and honestly anna can can you answer
this one or try to answer this last
question
um once we get consensus once we
do have vaccines and people taking them
when could things start returning to
normal
yeah that's a really hard question to
answer so i think um
based off of some of the trials that are
really um
in kind of the final phases in phase
three of their clinical trials right now
those are looking promising
so i think we might actually have
vaccines possibly by the end of this
year early next year
um but yeah it's really hard to say
worldwide how we'll be able to
distribute those
and kind of return to a normal society
so yeah i'm hoping for early next year
but i'm also just
cautiously optimistic fingers crossed
bioengineer anna blakeney thank you very
much
thank you your questions now on the
coronavirus
keep sending them into our youtube
channel and dw science correspondent
derek williams will take care of the
rest
can you tell us more about the bcg
vaccine clinical trial that's currently
underway
well there are a few studies looking at
this but i think the one that you're
talking about which has received the
most media coverage
is called the brace trial um it's being
conducted in several countries across
the globe it involves
around 10 000 volunteers many of them
health care workers but before we go any
further i need to provide
a little more background the bcg vaccine
which has been around
for close to a century is usually
associated with tuberculosis prevention
though it also appears to help prevent
or at least reduce the deadliness of a
range
of other infections the theory is
that the bcg vaccine is sort of a
generalist vaccine that helps
strengthen the immune response to many
respiratory diseases
by enhancing your innate immunity
however it's no longer widely given in
countries where
tb has grown rare but in countries where
it's still
endemic and the bcg vaccine is is still
common
there are lots of studies showing that
it impacts things like
child mortality rates and and many of
those same countries
also appear to have lower mortality
rates
in the covet 19 pandemic the problem is
is that it's hard to show that the bcg
vaccine
is maybe one reason why because a lot of
other factors
could also be playing a role it's kind
of hard
to filter out all of the noise and
that's what the brace trial
is trying to do in a systematic way
and if we don't have a more specific
targeted
covid19 vaccine soon and the study shows
that the bcg vaccine
does indeed help lower covid19
transmission
or severity it could one day be seen as
a kind of
stop gap tool in the pandemic but
but that's still a big if
well policy makers in germany are
already grappling with who will be
first in line for a successful vaccine
that won't initially be enough to
inoculate the population of more than 80
million
health minister jens spahn is calling
for a rigorous public
what's debate what's also important to
me personally is that this debate is not
only a parliamentary political
and not only a scientific one but that
we take this discussion to every lunch
table
to every workplace to every circle of
friends and acquaintances
and that it is discussed in germany in
the end it needs a high level of
acceptance
acceptance well let's bring in dw
political correspondent
nina haaser on this
are you there nina i'm here yeah right
there
i hear you but i don't see yours okay so
what are the recommendations that the
health minister is considering
well as we heard and with today's news
obviously
it's looking increasingly likely that
germany
says to have a vaccine against this sort
of uh the coronavirus pretty soon the
government is actually hoping
maybe end of the year or spring next
year
but in spain um called the news
of pfizer and biontech with their news
that the
um vaccine that they're developing and
that it
is effective very encouraging but what's
already clear is that there will not be
enough initially for everybody straight
away which is why the government
and its agencies are trying to prepare
the german population that there will
have to be priority groups
and yen span set up a commission to
discuss these questions
and as we heard he wants this discussion
to happen nationwide so that there is
maximum consent with the strategy once
the vaccine is actually
there and the idea is now to set up
vaccination centers
so that local gps don't have to make
that decision
who do you give the vaccine to and who
doesn't get it
and first the vaccine would be a given
to
people who are who belong to the high
risk groups to avoid severe cases of
covet 19
and then to people who look after these
people like doctors nurses etc
and to other people who are exposed to
the virus a lot and then to people who
work in positions that are vital to
maintaining public life
like the police etc what's important to
add is that the vaccination would
not be compulsory it would be voluntary
and the health minister believes that
two-thirds of germans would need to be
vaccinated
for the vaccine to be able to stop the
dynamic of the virus
okay so that's that that's a
conversation that is uh that's been
started
um yen span has also repeated his
warning about the need to
avoid overwhelming germany's health
system
what is the current situation nina
well we keep saying record keep seeing
record numbers in new infections and
when you look at the situation in
hospitals
experts are saying that the situation is
currently even worse than it was during
the peak times in spring
because there are a lot more covert
patients in regular hospital beds
and many of them will end up in icu
and it takes four weeks for the current
record numbers in new infections to then
translate into
much higher numbers in icu patients and
some hospitals
have already exceeded their capacity
their transferring patients to other
clinics
of course germany is still coping fairly
well there are currently some 8
400 free icu beds nationwide but if the
numbers develop
in the way they have done over the past
weeks um
this number could dwindle very fast and
that is the big concern
okay dw correspondent nina haser thank
you
well of course this is a big news that
everyone's looking for at the moment
i'll just repeat that german-based
pharmaceutical company beyond tech
says one of the vaccines it's developing
is more than 90 percent effective
against
covered 19. so how is this affecting the
markets
well chelsea delane is our financial
correspondent in
frankfurt welcome at chelsea how's this
news
gone down there
it's been a huge uh huge boost for
markets here in frankfurt
the dax was already up about two percent
on the u.s election results but
after this news came in from pfizer and
beyond tech we saw
uh markets really shoot up the dax is up
almost six percent right now and
we're seeing this particularly and and
the stocks of
things like airlines and travel
companies for example lufthansa the
german airline is up about 20
the british airways owner iig is up
about 30 so clearly
a lot of investors are now betting on uh
some sort of return to normality
in the near future and there had been a
little bit concern because some of these
trials have been halted for safety
concerns that the timeline was going to
get pushed further and further out but
this has really
given people a lot of hope that perhaps
by you know early next year we could
start seeing this
vaccine being rolled out still
we have some some public health
officials warning that even as even as
these vaccines are approved it likely
won't hit the full population
uh until much further out into next year
so a little bit too early to
to be jumping to these hopes of a new
return to normality thank you for that
chelsea delaney in frankfurt
you